I think you deserve to be the world
champion definitely wanted to feel that
feeling forever leaving the competition
is Darcy live the chance of winning that
title was gone then I got the call to be
a wild card
I am grateful to have another chance to
win this competition but it's also like
terrifying
how am I gonna come back and blow the
roof off the place
Darcie petunia great to see you as well
oh my god what's it been like to come
back and compete against all these
amazing talents it isn't crazy I mean I
have seen the talents from all over the
world on TV and you know it's great to
see them and they've inspired me what's
been the biggest difference for you
between the first time you competed in
this time probably the stakes are higher
now that it's like the best of the best
against each other it's like stakes are
way higher the pressures on and it's
just the competitions what tougher
petunia how are you feeling about
tonight that's all that matters well
good luck to both of you
[Music]
[Applause]
you